so how does that map on to uh an actual
relationship you know you talk about
like
not just being the nice guy
um you talk about maybe Awakening or or
embodying or including the part of you
that maybe is the what is that
what does that look like in kind of
everyday
relationship or marriage yeah I think
every day in a relationship with a woman
I mean if you're dealing with that
notion of
that concept it's using the word no more
I think guys are just so used to
stamping everything yes they're stand-up
comics that do entire entire routines
that make the auditorium erupt and
laughter when they say something like
just give your wife a stamp that just
says yes yes yes yes and stamp
everything right so I think guys are
accustomed to
co-signing everything that their wife
wants to do and the last thing women
want is to lead a relationship they want
to be led they want to be with a giant
they want to be with a guy that gets it
that knows how to be a man but they will
test your frame like they will test
your frame you know they will they will
do things that will systematically
weaken your leadership and your
masculinity not intentionally because
they want to plessify you or they want
to make you weaker but it's in their
nature to test you to to see if you're
the most competent version of a man that
they can get because of their
hypergamous nature and all that means is
they just want to be with a giant I want
to be with the best guy that they can
get a lot of pieces to the opposal when
it comes to that notion but saying no is
an easy thing any guy can do it uh babe
I want to go to this um dog festival
called woofstock where there's going to
be a bunch of fluffy white doggies there
and we're all going to put costumes in
our dogs and do all kinds of you know
fluffy white doggy things with our
friends or no you know I have things to
do I have a like you don't explicitly or
overtly perhaps state that I have a dent
in the universe to uh you know to make
like I have things to do I've I have
more important things in my life that I
need to do but even at the dating phase
you know when she tries to draw you into
things that you're not particularly
interested in one or two uh don't serve
your grander purpose or narrative guys
are too happy to abandon you know their
hopes goals and dreams and purpose in
life to go and placate a woman to go to
some uh fluffy white dog uh conference
or exhibition where they're showcasing
the newest knit sweaters and pink
collars
um no I have other obligations but enjoy
you know I'll see you on Sunday at that
you know family event or I'll catch up
with you on Monday night you know like
we normally get together sort of thing
it starts early on in the relationship
just by making a simple statement one
word no and it doesn't usually require
an explanation just the word itself
should be sufficient I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out